lotiko and here korinyang are worried
about their baby boy he's seven months
old and sick weak and hungry there isn't
enough food because of a drought
his mother can't get enough food to eat
and can't produce enough milk for him
they lost another child in february they
say he starved
he got sick and died i don't know what
to do about this other child she might
also die because she's hungry
millions of families across the horn of
africa are hungry and desperate
they're facing the worst drought the
region has seen in 40 years
in kenya more than three and a half
million people need immediate help
aid agencies say nearly 800 000 of them
are children
the animals too are dying as it gets
hotter and drier
people out here tend to move around a
lot looking for food and water for
themselves and their animals many areas
are remote the nearest hospital can be
hours away some of the women here say
they can leave very early in the morning
and only get to the clinic late at night
cases of malnutrition are rising at this
local health center health workers are
struggling to cope they say when some of
the children get here they are severely
malnourished maltreation has been here
for so long
myself i can say it is a chronic
migration
but it has wasn't because of the drought
for the last two years we have not
received rainfall
[Music]
grace gibes says many children are going
to school hungry she says this drought
is the worst she has ever seen some of
them
they're just dying
and we have
nothing to just feed them and our
animals
all die because we just depend for
animals
what little water is left in streams and
rivers may soon run out desperate
families stress the little that's left
and can only hope the rains soon fall
again
harumatasa al jazeera masturbate county
northern kenya